до представлення наших спікерів я так
напевно буду представляти просто по
черзі В перш за все хотів би
дати можливість кожному з них сказати
пару слів за себе за своє бачення але
Перший Національний експерт
програми її фоскел координатор групи
експертів
поскай фон солідарності Геннадія русанов
пане Геннадійович щось хочете додати про
себе два слова
не знаю що про мене додати Привітайте
учасників Всіх вітаю по-перше Дуже
приємно бачити Дуже багато знайомих
обличчя людей з якими маючись бути
знайомий вже дуже-дуже багато років дуже
приємно що є така сталість в системі
люди які дійсно переживають за системою
професійної освіти дбають про неї
намагаються розвивати і створювати якісь
нові речі змінювати систему на краще
навіть такі складні часи і ще раз дуже
приємно вас бачити і тих кого знаю і тих
з ким немає часті бути знайомим теж
будемо сподіватись що в нас буде
цікавитись Так дякую дуже наступне Я
хотів би представити
співробітницю управління професійного
навчання та міжнародного співробітництва
державного центру зайнятості пані Лілія
Грабовського вона також
може про себе дуже багато розказати але
я думаю що ми зможемо дискутувати Якщо
хочете будь ласка спробуйте як мікрофон
ще раз вас вітаю колеги дуже добре
працюють мікрофони я ж все спрацювало
добре
щодо даної теми яка є на нашій сесії
сьогодні співпраця системою професійної
освіти та ринку праці можу сказати що я
в минулому житті як я роблю казати з
багаторічним досвідом роботи в
профтехосвіті саме і я розумію ту
синергію яка має бути між закладами
освіти з боку закладу освіти насправді і
вже з боку державної установи а ще й з
боку роботодавця заради якого і для
якого в нас є професійна освіта і є наші
випускники наші ваші випускники є
доросла населення яке вимагає
перепідготовки і саме якими вони мають
бути якими вони мають виходити від нас
залежить саме Від фахівців фахівців
закладів професійно-технічної освіти
насправді я вже казала що людський
капітал який має система єдиної освіти
це основний
кладязь який надає можливості
роботодавцям отримати дійсно
кваліфікованих робітників на ринку праці
дякую Гарних співбесіди нам дякую пані
Лілія
наступним Я хотів би попросити також
представитись але перш за все це Валерій
Сафронов заступник голови
директора
Запорізького виконавчого директора
запорізької обласної федерації
роботодавців Який Ну залучався до різних
активностей і може поділитися досвідом
організації такої співпраці п Валерію
два слова про себе щоб також спробувати
ну по-перше щодо цього проекту євро
Skills в цьому проекті була співпраця
через таку німецьку організацію як секва
вона вийшла на наше Запоріжжя через
федерацію роботодавців і ми
співпрацювали в такому напрямку
співпраця
комерційних підприємств з
професійно-технічними навчальними
закладами через дуальну освіту я вам
скажу що наробки були добрі гарні і
вони мали свій позитивний характер Ну і
ще можу сказати що в Запоріжжі як ніде
мабуть
поєднана з співпраця Федерації
роботодавців той сайт безпосередньою
роботодавців з департаментом освіти і
через них на професійні технічні
навчальні заклади коледжі та вищі і у
нас є свій меморандум щодо спів ситуації
я скажу що у нас добре це напрацьовано і
воно нам допомагає поєднати наші зусилля
роботодавці і професійних закладах щодо
підготовки та підготовки робітників
дякую дякую пане Валерію зараз будете
ділитися своїми напрацюваннями і
досвідом як я казав на вступні доповіді
з скарбами якими накопичили протягом
організації цієї співпраці але
перед тим як ми перейдемо до якихось
обговорень у нас система має декілька
зрізів якими сьогодні будемо пробувати
охопити традиційно ми говоримо не тільки
про первинну підготовку А також про
навчання дорослих і перенавчання Тобто
це ближче до
навчання протягом життя другий момент що
є у нас різні формати навчання які
особливо актуальні саме для ринку праці
Тобто це не тільки формальна освіта а це
ще й інші фор здобуття знань Які
розвиваються в країні вони вже існують і
в деяких сферах вони домінують Я б
сказав би якщо наприклад згадувати
it спеціалізація ті галузі то там
формальна освіта відіграє Ну порівняно
меншу роль ніж здобуття навичок і
кваліфікації всередині самої самої сфери
але так чи інакше Ну всі ми з вами в
Україні і знаємо що відбувається в
Україні і ситуація
не те що динамічна а змінюється Ну
просто кардинальним чином Тому перше щоб
я хотів би спитати всіх наших спікерів
зробити таку оцінку ситуації яка існує
сьогодні якби кожен з вас оцінив
здатність існуючого сьогодні системи
професійної освіти професійно-технічної
освіти
як ця система здатна сьогодні реагувати
на
зміни на ринку праці на нові виклики які
стоять перед країною перед суспільством
хто
може поділитися думками з цього приводу
якщо
будь ласка пане Геннадій будь ласка А
ось в мікрофон будь ласка
думок насправді багато я спробую їх
виструктувати трошки коротко
це говорили про те що в нас є нові зміни
там нові виклики Очевидно вони є але
як це не парадоксально
їх не так багато
те що ми бачимо ми досліджуємо ринок
праці вже кілька років поспіль дивимось
на ситуацію Ми і взагалі
маємо можливість працювати з системою
професійної освіти вже дуже багато років
насправді ті виклики які стояли перед
професійною освітою до війни Ну по-перше
ми повинні розуміти що війна у нас йде
не
з 22-го року а йде вже дуже багато років
ми говоримо зараз про
повномасштабних вторгнення а тому
насправді ті виклики які існували в
системі Це демографічна ситуація яка в
нас систематично погіршується системно і
довго погіршується це економічні виклики
це виклики
які створює війна з точки зору
збільшення кількості з людей з
психологічними фізичними травами
людей яким потрібна
перенавчання люди які переміщуються з
своїх домівок втрачає свої домівки На
жаль всі ці виклики вони були і до цього
насправді
повномасштабне вторгнення просто ці
виклики збільшили деколи в деяких
випадках збільшували дуже-дуже-дуже
багато разів і деякі тенденції
пришвидшилися Так що ми говорили про
міграцію таким потічком то зараз
міграція набула величезних масштабів
дуже багато людей очевидно виїхали тому
насправді
якихось нових викликів не так супер
багато вони просто стали більшими більш
актуальними вони просто стали фізично
більшими тобто масштаби цих викликів
масштаби цих проблем Вони просто дуже
швидко
збільшилась на жаль Але тим не менше як
показала ситуація
більшість систем Української держави і в
тому числі системи професійної освіти
витримали ці виклики
і насправді я би хотів щоб
ці виклики сприймалися як дуже-дуже
велика можливість зараз дійсно є час
такими ж самими швидкими темпами
запроваджувати зміни тому що за моїм
суб'єктивним спостереженням якщо ми
подивимось на всі інші ланки систем
системи освіти в Україні то насправді
система професійної освіти є найбільш
наближеною до реальності Скажімо так
тобто і насправді найшвидше реагує на на
зміни Хотілося би звичайно швидше краще
більше ефективніше завжди Хочеться
швидше краще більше ефективніше але
враховуючи ті ресурси і ті умови в яких
працює система Насправді Я маю
можливість спостерігати за цим процесом
з 2005 року вже 18 років насправді
система рухається в принципі в дуже-дуже
правильному напрямку деколи швидше
деколи повільніше деколи вперед деколи
трошки вбік то залежить від багатьох
факторів від наявності міжнародної
підтримки яка дуже важлива бо очевидно
Україна не зможе подолати багато проблем
які існують самотужки деколи залежить
від політиків їх політичної волі чи
відсутності такої волі але в принципі
загальний тренд в системі
довготерміновий тренд як на мене є
позитивним є кілька таких викликів до
яких треба зараз поставити дуже серйозно
Як на мене найбільше такий виклик Це
просто зменшення кількості студентів в
системі і тут системі треба дивитись
трошки ширше умовно кажучи знаходити
нові цільові групи і підлаштовуватись
під потреби цих груп
короткий філософські Можливо трошки
думки але так Так дякую
Шановні колеги я думаю що у вас в
процесі того як ви слухаєте наші
дискусії будуть виникати питання будь
ласка ви маєте можливість їх написати і
є моя колега яка
дозволить їй зібрати і ми спробуємо їх
обговорити тому Я запрошую бути
учасниками цієї дискусії але якщо
повертаючись до системи професійної
освіти яка у нас складається і закладів
професійно-технічної освіти і з центрів
підвищення чи перекваліфікації
підвищення кваліфікації державних цін
навчальних центрів державного служби
зайнятості
Як оцінити нас од готовність наскільки
ефективно Ми зараз реагуємо
на п'ятірочку на 12
пані Ліля Ну що я можу сказати з боку
освітянина як ви кажете на 12 то
забагато але й мало поставити не можу А
можна не оцінювати в балах я хочу
сказати насправді
Державна служба зайнятості зараз трохи
змінює свій формат і ми розпочали
співпрацю безпосередньо за роботодавцями
з такими великими роботодавцями які
наразі потребують кадрового потенціалу
більш знаєте так синергійно і більш
іншими підходами що маю сказати Маю
сказати що професійна освіта а-а вміє
реагувати Як казав пан Геннадій Він
завжди Така каже хотілося б швидше
бистріше і скоріше але не реагуємо
реагуємо на виклики наразі ринку праці
як я кажу Я вже сьогодні це казала І
багато на рівні держави про це свідчать
насправді роботодавець це потребує
кваліфікованого робітника і навчання
кваліфікованих робітників за короткий
проміжок часу саме зараз саме для
закладів освіти є пріоритетним насправді
як кажуть всі і я так кажу навчання
перенавчання дорослого населення Зараз
ми співпрацюємо з особами які мають
бажання отримати Вау через що я хочу і
можу сказати ми вже станемо Олексієм
сьогодні мали з цього приводу розмову
насправді дуже багато наших громадян які
мають вищу освіту втратили свою роботу в
якомусь окремому регіоні мали змогу
переїхати переміститися нашою країною
потрапили до регіону де його
кваліфікація кваліфікація спеціаліста не
є Скажімо так затребуваною вони готові
перенавчатися готові перенавчатися за
робітничими професіями Що наприклад як
для мене стало
зробити Ось таким викликом що насправді
Так в нас є
[музика]
багато-багато наших осіб які мають вищу
освіту але вони наразі готові бути
конкурентоспроможними на ринку праці
Вони готові прийти перенавчання але ж не
готові вони це робити довго тому що
кожен роботодавець який має за потреби
отримати для себе кваліфікованого
робітника Він має Це бажання зараз
сьогодні і коли маєш розмову за
роботодавцем вони кажуть чекайте колеги
але я зараз не можу вам сказати що буде
з моїм підприємством Ні завтра аніж за
півроку аніж за рік тому якщо брати
професійну освіту треба змінювати
змінювати напрямки підготовки це є
часткові кваліфікації це є
короткострокове навчання яке дозволить
задовільнити ту потребу роботодавців які
наразі є безпосередньо в даний про часу
дякую дякую пані Лілія ви знаєте ми якби
рухаємося От у нас є
імпульт або рекомендація першого
експерта певної Геннадія орієнтуватися
на ширше коло цільових аудиторій тому що
є проблема з демографією Скажімо так Є
пропозиція
освітянина від центру зайнятості
стосовно розвитку форматів надання
освітніх послуг а тепер було б гарно аби
роботодавці сказали зі свого боку як
вони оцінюють можливості співпраці з
системою професійної освіти можливо які
моменти успішні або яких чого реально не
вистачає
Ну по-перше я хотів би декілька слів
сказати щодо
співпраці з секвою тобто от щоб воно вже
те саме якщо дозволити так так будь
ласка але я я розумію значить просто що
коли ця проектна організація ввійшла до
нас до Запорізької області війни ще не
було і ми дійсно працювали щодо дуальної
освіти поміж
нашими підприємствами і професійними
закладами ця робота йшла добре гарна але
в лютому 22-го року розпочалась війна і
на жаль і це для нас дуже велика втрата
і гори що більш не В 75% нашої землі
запорізької відійшло від загарбника і
в зв'язку з тим що був великий відтік
робітничої сили молодих людей які йшли з
його
з півдня і з сходу перейшли до нас в
Запоріжжя быстра
перевантажились ми і почали з німцями
готувати по короткостроковим програмам
фахівців перепідготовка йшла
перепідготовку ми зробили за кошт
німецької сторони
перепідготовку ми
здійснили щодо Машиністів кранів
металургійного виробництва для наших
металургійних підприємств
Токарів вони
з усім потрібні і електромонтерів
ремонтників більш того ще одна така
напрямок був у нас ви знаєте що кожний
три роки наші майстри виробничого
навчання повинні пройти стажування
ковід війна відтермінували це і ми
провели стажування опять же за рахунок
німецької сторони ми провели стажування
майстрив щодо електротехнічних напрямків
всього Німецька сторона і небагато за
потратили але
велику кількість ми перепідготували
потратила 550 тисяч гривень на на ці всі
заходи а тепер я хотів би сказати щодо
співпраці дійсної
роботодавців і професійної технічної
навчальних закладів Ну якщо відверто то
Ну дійсно наверное сьогодні бали ми не
будемо встановити ми будемо казати де у
нас добре І де у нас ще працювати нам і
працювати
гібкось єсть але її не недостатньо чому
недостатньо
мені терміново Треба підготувати три
горлових де і як я його підготую
ніхто не про ліцензований а вони
потрібні ви знаєте як це виробництво ми
робимо Але це більше йде
подпольна так сказати а не дійсно
поэтому я хотів би отут звернити
звернутися до аудиторії щодо таких
питань як
зміна у слові ліцензування і атестації
якщо ми ці завдання не зробимо то ми так
і будемо ми вже 30 років розмовляємо
щодо вдосконалення ліцензування і 30
років Ми все про продовжимо всю ту же
е-е
наступаємо на ті самі граблі
що я хотів тепер декілька слів щодо
кваліфікаційних центрів дуже велика
робота дуже гарна Робота потрібна робота
але ви знаєте я як і бувший про втехиз і
сьогодні роботодавець я можу сказати
чому
професійно-технічне навчальний заклад
який може має ліцензію
атестований щодо підготовки токаря чому
йому треба по нової проходити атестацію
щодо кваліфікаційного центру по токаря
оце мені трохи незрозуміло ту треба
робити але треба підходи трохи
змінити на це те саме
в нас взагалі я вам скажу що ми
пов’язані і будемо працювати і повинні
працювати І будемо розвивати нашу
співпрацю
професійних закладів і роботодавців
дякую дякую пане Валерію стосовно таких
якби інформації про можливі напрямки і
це вже трошки ми переходимо в дискусію
більш глибоку як побудувати ці місточки
між
різними сферами інтересів між сферою
бізнесу яка звичайно не має фокусі
освіту як основним видом діяльності
Скажем так а є навчальними закладами які
мають освіту як основний вид діяльності
досить часто зустрічаєш ну стикаюся
ситуація коли
підприємства не мають або достатньо
мотивація або ресурсів або от як пан
Валерій також сказав є потреба шту чному
продукті невеликій кількості
спеціалістів вузького профілю і масова
система освіти вона звичайно з цим не
вправляється але ми маємо також
використовувати можливості які Я
впевнений сьогодні в державі вже у нас
зроблені це система
інформація або неформальної освіти
система яку зараз ми намагаємось
розвивати
більш відкрита і надавати доступ різним
категоріям населення навіть якщо вони
пройшли навчання і можуть
продемонструвати ці навички просто їх
підтвердити тому в даному контексті
цікаво було б також от
спитати Я знаю що пан Геннадій робив
багато досліджень разом з
роботодавцями з державної служби
зайнятості стосовно які ж такі навички
чи які професії
затребувані і питання буде приблизно
наступним наскільки є на співпадіння
саме на рівні
того що вимагають роботодавця по
дослідженнях і з тим що пропонує ринок
освіти
дорогому готелю ми з кожного свій
мікрофон
Отже на співпадінні є різним насправді
Якщо так не вдаватись в конкретній
професії бо їх дуже багато в цілому ми
бачимо більшість більше співпадіння в
технічних навичках чи в професійних
тобто умовно кажучи якщо ми беремо
умовного токаря чи зварювальника то
навчання власне навичкам токарної справи
Чи Зварювання в цілому відбувається
добре тобто і роботодавці оцінюють ці
навички позитивно і ми так само
проводили опитування випускників і
випускники так само оцінюють
релевантність цих навичок до їх роботи в
цьому позитивно тобто тут якби розриву
такого сильного немає насправді є кілька
блок професій в професійній освіті який
в принципі мав би мав би щезнути але це
це більше питання Скажем так
що найбільші розрив де ми бачимо навіть
не то що
значить
Training де це віч кенвіколд Soft Skills
I loved
від
професій зрештою нас є багато даних за
цим не буду знову ж таки вдаватися от
тут власне є найбільше не співпадіння
тобто роботодавці хочуть цих навичок
вони хочуть щоб токарі зварювальники
вміла не тільки
зварювати чи обробляти метал а і
нормально комунікувати працювати в
команді і приходити вчасно
там не знаю спілкуватися з іноземними
мовами і так далі І так далі
і тому професійну освіту цього не робить
тобто цього компоненту в принципі не
існує навчальних програмах і
викладачі дуже часто не вміють цьому
вчити не вчать цьому не бачить в цьому
потреби
з різних причин це не робиться але цього
фактично не має
те саме стосується підприємницьких
навичок цього теж не існує в нас освіта
традиційно орієнтована на те що людина
на зараз пішла працювати на когось тобто
пішла на завод фабрику Я не знаю ще десь
підприємство і пішла там Працювати
натомість можливість цієї людини бути
самозайністю або створити якісь
невеличкі підприємство не розглядається
і це є цей погано насправді
ну ось ось такі основні розриви які на
нашу думку не то що на нашу думку а
власне те що дані нам показують такі
довготермінові Отакі загальні тенденції
існують тобто дуже коротко підсумувався
з технічними навичками в цілому все
більш-менш окей залежить від професії
але середня температура по палаті Окей
що стосується м'яких навичок
підприємницьких навичок
Все дуже не окей цього майже немає І це
важливо Так дякую Я впевнений що
освітяни зможуть зреагувати на на Ці
коментарі тому що ми трошки перескочимо
я б пана Валерія хочу спитати Як би ви
оцінили в чому розрив чого не вистачає
професійної освіти з позиції роботодавця
чи дійсно технічні навички які дає зараз
професійну освіта співпадають з
потребами технології які
використовуються і все в порядку тут і
чи дійсно є необхідність сильна якби
посилення
м'яких навичок або комунікаційних
соціальних
Яке ваше відчуття я хотів би відповісти
так якщо ми говоримо про впровадження
дуальної освіти то сам безпосередньо
впровадження дуальної освіти вона
згладжує оце якраз питання і може його
вирішити це питання але я щодо дуальної
освіти
підходи
будемо так в Німеччині і у нас це різні
підходи з самого початку Як там йде
набору учнів
учень
підприємство
торгово-промислова палата
У нас тут навпаки директор сам він і
токарь и пекарь і менеджер і все про він
сам набирає сам його
розподіляє людей і прочер то есть сам
підхід не те це але коли вже цей
зроблено і коли почали ми подивились по
цій дуальній коли вже пішла дуальна
освіта той якраз оці Всі комунікації все
інше воно вже набуває сили і можна
говорити що да воно
вирівнюється і можна говорити що учнями
підготуємо добре під
безпосередньо оце робоче місце де він
здійснює дуальну освіту Так дякую дуже
ну модель дуального навчання чи дуальної
освіти Вона має певну специфі ку я з цим
Згоден але я впевнений що освітяни Ну на
жаль у нас є
обмеженою зараз можливість
охарактеризувати весь досвід який зараз
реалізує Міністерство освіти і в сфері
підприємницьких навичок як Вони
намагаються їм цементувати різні курси
але я хотів би пані лілію спитати
стосовно присутності в структурі
навчальних курсів саме оцієї складової
пов'язаної
в системі центрів зайнятості це
затребувані курси затребувана підготовка
як вона імплементується і чи якісь
можливо інші розриви ви бачите по
тенденціях ринку праці перед тим як ми
підемо вже встановлювати усі місточки
або можливі формати моделі співпраці
будь ласка
е Ну насправді так Державна служба
зайнятості має своїй структурі 11
центрів професійно-технічної освіти
наразі функціонує тільки вісім центрів
деякі з центрів е-е в нас внаслідок
військової агресії є е-е вже
непридатними для організації навчального
процесу а-а але що маю сказати щодо
особливо
освітніх програм які відповідають
підприємницькій діяльності насправді Так
в нас всі 8 центрів професійно-технічної
освіти наразі мають освітні програми які
надають можливість слухачам отримати
такий базовий курс щодо організації
своєї особистої підприємницької
діяльності створення бізнес-планування
створення бізнес-ідей насправді вони
користуються попитом чому користуються
попитом тому що є державні програми які
зараз
державна служба зайнято спільно з
міністерством економіки
реалізують щодо надання мікрогрантів
особа в нашому громадянинам України які
мають на Це бажання
насправді
допомагають саме в створенню
бізнес-планування тому що і визначено
законодавча база
якою Необхідно володіти для того щоб
розпочати Саме цей процес навіть щоб
визначити отут бізнес ідею ці освітні
програми користуються попитом ті особи
які мають на Це бажання в нас Навіть
зараз мають можливість подавання онлайн
заявки подають онлайн заявку хочемо
повчитися за такою освітньою програмою
всі ці освітні програми висвітлені
безпосередньо на сайті Державної служби
зайнятості кожна особа має змогу це
зробити
щодо совскерів щодо яких навичок можу
сказати Таким чином насправді так
насправді роботодавці дуже багато
зустрічей проводимо з роботодавцями і
зараз роботодавці вважають що саме перше
Саме основне і під час опитування ми це
визначили особа має бути відповідальною
по-перше особа має бути відповідальна
вона навіть не завжди для роботодавця
повинна мати харди вона повинна мати в
собі здатність і можливість навчатися
роботодавець готовий перенавчати фахівця
який приходить до нього але він має бути
готовим до цього дуже багато наразі
в нас різних категорій і вразливих
категорій яких великим чином ми
намагаємося охватити з різних боків але
з слів роботодавця не завжди в нас
особливо вразливі категорії осіб мають
бажання
працевлаштуватись мають бажання
перенавчатись і є відповідальними щодо
свого подальшого працевлаштування Так
дякую дякую пані Лілія думаю що загальна
ситуація зрозуміла і Ну я впевнений що
освітяни які сьогодні перебувають Ви
також можете задати питання або
прокоментувати якісь речі ми вже почали
отримувати ці питання тому я вас щиро
запрошую їх писати і ми будемо
обговорювати будь ласка
Я напевно дав можливість відповісти на
це питання тому що воно стосується
зараз дискусії А ви можете писати в
принципі будь-яке питання І ми їх будемо
опрацьовувати трошки пізніше от моя
колега пані Тетяна буде їх збирати будь
ласка
ну власне питання є два перше
я зачитаю просто щоб розуміли на що
відповідає ви зазначили що тренд
розвитку про фтеху освіти довгостроковій
перспективі і правильний який це який це
тренд і Який його риси
[музика]
тренд
загальний тренд це краще розуміння
ситуації
Ну я розумію що це таке дуже
загальне загальна відповідь але ну
спробую трошки пояснити знову ж таки маю
честі можливість працювати з прав в тих
освіти вже довший час з 2005 року і
якщо ми подивимось на те
попри всі негативи зараз говоримо про
загальний довготерміновий тренд
ми бачимо те що система по-перше
децентралізувалася це вже добре тобто
рішення спускається на нижчий рівень там
де вони і мали би прийматись на
максимальну низький рівень де вони могли
мали би її прийматись по-друге є
набагато краще розуміння своїх ват
тобто система розуміє де є проблеми де є
недоліки
і в принципі як їх виправляти якщо там
на початку 2000 у 2005 році взагалі не
було розуміння того що щоб взагалі треба
змінюватись на нашу все все нормально
все класно працює все у Києві в нас була
найкраща в світі Радянська система
профтехосвіти базові підприємства Ну все
все класно працює то зараз є розуміння
того де є проблеми є розуміння можливих
сценаріїв механізмів їх вирішення вони
не завжди вдарив вони не завжди вдаються
робиться багато помилок Але в цьому є
розуміння цих проблем це є величезний
величезний Крок вперед Ми вже зараз не
говоримо про те що в нас все добре тобто
визнання проблеми цей Перший крок до її
вирішення Зараз ми не просто визнали
проблему ми ідентифікували конкретні
проблеми за конкретними галузями Ну і де
друкуємо проблему в управлінні
фінансування
законодавстві навчання викладачів
в системі проходження практики і так
далі тобто ці проблеми фокусуються Ми
дивимось вже на моїх категоризуємо
дивимось які вони вивчаємо їх аналізуємо
і пропонуємо різні механізми рішень
очевидно не завжди ці механізми
спрацьовують не завжди це рішення
спрацьовують з об'єктивних і
суб'єктивних причин
ковіду там і війни є просто базова
спроможність системи є величезні
проблеми Скажем так генетичні тобто які
забули закладені в систему насправді
радянські радянською економікою
радянської системи і влади і які для
того щоб їх вилікувати потрібно або мати
дуже багато ресурсу і дуже велику
політичну волю і робити це швидко
хірургічно або це вимагає довгого часу
оскільки ресурсів не так багато і так
само треба розуміти що ми зрештою
Працюємо з обмеженою кількістю
інституцій і з тими людьми які нам в
більшості залишились спадок теж
від радянської системи цих людей теж
треба змінювати це займає час люди Ну
вони ростуть і змінюються з певною
швидкістю
і пришвидшити цей процес не завжди
Можливо тому в цілому тренд як на мене
правильний
є насправді кілька таких екзистенційних
речей які треба виправляти
це стосується і залучення додаткових
людей в систему ми говоримо про в цілому
системи не тільки заклади про
промоціювання системи і в цьому теж дуже
багато насправді цього робиться є є суве
в цьому і Очевидно в змінні структури
фінансування не так опції як структури
рішення тут обговорюється Вони є на
столі вони є в політиків їх багато цих
рішень можливих Ну якщо вони будуть
прийняті Коли вони будуть прийняті як
вони будуть прийняті будемо бачити але
це така Можливо трошки розлога відповідь
Але
спробував як як міг і друге питання
просто тут є Так так я просто хотів
тільки ще сказати автора це наші
тут професійних кваліфікацій і друге
питання
чи є навчання Soft Skills з завданням
профтехосвіти ну коротке відповідь Так
довга буде дуже довгою тому не буду
займати час насправді це є завдання всіх
ланок системи бо без цього аудіо
з боку школи не підготовлена з боку
сім'ї до сприйняття цих навичок ну при
всій повазі Я знаю що таке
тайм-менеджмент всі знають що таке тай
менеджмент але це можливо не завдання
професійної освіти вчити цьому або не
тільки професійна освіта а друге питання
яке тут можливо теж важливе це те що
якщо це дійсно робиться система освіти
то згідно нашим традиціям це має бути
стандартизовано описано навчання
відповідні педагоги і це має бути
проходити якщо ми говоримо про завдання
всієї системи освіти зі школи і до
інституту це величезні інвестиції в
розвиток
людського капіталу педагогічного
капіталу інвестиції в розвиток системи
освіти тому що якщо це стандарт Він має
бути єдиний Я так розумію і навчання та
й менеджменту має відбуватися однаково
що в Вінниці Що в Житомирі що в
Чернігові відповідно з відповідними
наслідками до цього
дякую
Я дуже коротко про Пана Геннадія
поверніться будь ласка
наші колеги які спостерігають за онлайн
вони просто не бачать не знаю чи бачите
мене така вже приємна штука але
дуже коротко відрефоксую буквально Це
дійсно є завдання всіх ланок тут Я
абсолютно Правий що стосується
стандартизації там і так далі Ну в мене
є колеги він буде зараз в нас з ним вже
до багаторічна філософська дискусія щодо
стандартів і так далі
знаєте стандарти це добре але мені
здається що чого дуже сильно бракує
українській системі освіти всі не тільки
профтехосвіті це Свободи
[музика]
тому знаєте я не пам'ятаю хто хто
написав Я знову ж таки зараз цитую не
повністю але от в середньовічній Італії
в нас були там борджа
у всі один одного вбивали тобто були
заклади такі трошки коротше коротко от
було дуже дуже якби так різноманітно а в
Швейцарії в цей час все було дуже
спокійно і що ми маємо в результаті ми
маємо там Відродження а швейцарці дали
нам ну зараз більше дали але тоді це
годинник з кукушкою ну це жарт Звичайно
але Можливо трошки більше
різноманітності і цікавості і свободи
дасть нам більше цікавих результатів
Так дякую дуже за таку якби живе питання
Ну звичайно роботодавці мають центральну
роль в цій дискусії
пане Валерія тільки попрошу вас
зрезимувати недовго тому що я хочу
задати питання і для аудиторії для вас
яке орієнтовано на майбутнє будь ласка Я
хотів би зупинитись
щодо співпраці закладів і підприємств ви
знаєте Ми обходимо сьогодні
трьохсторонні угоду і коли були
радянські часи ми казали що це ярмо і
так сказать сьогодні Сьогодні ми прийшли
до того що вона потрібна ця
трьохстороння угода але
її бояться і коли учні бачать що тут є
дійсно чоткий такий посил
трьохсторонньої угоди цього професійного
закладу і
роботодавця вони стараються оминити це
оминути це питання але на западі
трьохстороння угода має свій сенс Вона
працює і чому дійсно коли роботодавець я
роботодавець затратив сили енергії кошти
підготував його і він став добрим
токарем але по випуску він пішов бо він
же свободна людина і ні не перед ким і
не чи Перечин не відповідає і ще хотів
би сказати Я е-е Ми дуже всі вдячні
роботодавці ваучерам це дуже велика
справа гарна справа але я ось тут хотів
би сказати від е-е роботодавців
Запоріжжя
45-15 Це дуже добре але 35 10 - це
взагалі було Ідемо у нас ми ми перейшли
до конкретики обговорюємо коди доступу
ринку праці до системи освіти і навпаки
добре колеги дякую ще раз нагадую про
можливі задати питання і сфокусувати
дискусію так як вам цікаво
Наразі я б хотів би нас залишилось не
так багато часу але кожному з вас задати
питання
стосовно того як ми в майбутньому маємо
змінитися щоб відбудувати Україну ми
маємо велику кількість як ми вже
обговорювали і накопичених до
військового періоду чи 14-го року Потім
з 14 по 22-й потім я не можу сказати що
ковід нам допоміг багато чого вирішити
Звичайно діджеталізацію він
простимулював суттєво але
якби наші шановні експерти
порекомендували всім учасникам нашої
дискусії
адаптуватися чи які моменти треба було б
рахувати щоб система професійної освіти
зустрілася чи допомогла роботодавцям
відбудувати нашу країну
три хвилини так щоб зібратися з думками
Я розумію що можливо дуже глобальне
питання
будь ласка пані Лілія Ну що я маю
сказати вже про це сьогодні була мова
саме перше і сама основне це професійна
освіта має стати ще більш гнучкою ніж
якою вона стала протягом трохи більше
останнього року
по-друге в будь-якому випадку насправді
І проведеним багатьом опитуванням які
були я була присутня на всіх
фокус-групах які проходили з
роботодавцями
іноді насправді навіть Я з рівня свого
була Ну так здивована
роботодавцями відсотків на 200 особливо
якщо брати сільськогосподарську галузь
не завжди заклади освіти готові в
матеріальному оснащенні до підготовки
тих кваліфікованих фахівців яких
потребує роботодавець
треба виявити гнучкість гнучкість ось
саме Олексію в тих сходах про який йде
мова і формах навчання це і так дуальна
освіта яка має можливість адаптувати
слухачів випускників безпосередньо до
умов роботи підприємства це також
дистанційна форма навчання яка наразі в
нас
включаючи як ми кажемо з поганого боку
ковід надала можливість такого
покращення
умов навчання кожного особа може і має
такий можливості прийти навчання з
будь-якого якого куточку України
насамперед і щодо того що
професійно-технічна освіта насправді
зараз Нам необхідно післявоєнний період
Нам необхідно не втратити тих кадрів які
насправді зараз є становленням цієї
освіти тієї команди яка
приймає участь в самій реформі
професійно-технічної освіти і щоб ці
люди дійсно залишились в цій системі і
продовжили цю роботу і покращували її
тому що якщо ми втратимо людський
капітал то не буде в нас можливості до
покращення самої системи освіти якось
так так Абсолютно згоден пані Лілія Я
наприклад Хотів би також відзначити що
якщо дивитися структуру інвестиційних
проектів про які ми очікуємо чи плануємо
для відбудови України Я впевнений що в
бюджеті цих витрат буде суттєво Ну не
менше напевно 30% займати вартість
робочої сили яка залучена до
імплементації цих проектів
чи погоджуються роботодавці з
необхідністю чи як от адресувати цей
момент ваучери ми вже зрозуміли і код ми
вже підібрали можливо якийсь додаткові
підказки я вам скажу додаткові додаткові
підказки надасть визволення його востока
України сьогодні горіхи в Гуляйполе
Василівка кам'янське повністю зруйноване
і тому сама оця відбудова Я думаю що
внесе такі корективи які ми сьогодні
даже може не не можемо передбачити А як
підготуватися хоча б а як до цього
підготуватися Ну я думаю що якраз оці
через
скорочені курси через через ті же
ваучери все це ото
поєднання оцих всіх заходів я
і думаю що вийде на ту оптимальну так
сказати лінію щодо підготовки та
перепідготовка робітничих кадрів тобто
формат буде народжуватися з практики по
принципу знизу вгору
добре добре зрозуміла ви знаєте в нас є
ще такий на початку ми вислухали інсайт
що важкі часи
народжують сильні проекти і це ці
можливості які відкривають ці важкі часи
Я попросив би може нашого Геннадія
русанова також зарезимувати як
адресувати відбудову через систему
профтеху
не забуваю що в мене є свій мікрофон
складне питання
насправді мені здається що системі
професійної освіти бути більш
адаптованою краще
реагувати на ті виклики які я зараз
треба кілька речей
інженери кажуть
найкраща частина в механізмі це такої
немає
Вона не ламається низької проблеми Мені
здається в системі треба дуже добре
подивитись і ще раз саму себе і
позбавитись цих частин які можливо не
дуже є ефективні це стосується і
закладів і інших інституцій і спрямувати
ресурси на щось інше
тобто стати крім того що більш гнучкою
просто більш
повороткою
швидшою тобто система яка має менше
механізмів які взаємозв'язки між
частинами є кращими Вона працює швидше
реагує на виклики швидше
друге треба перестати боятися власних
помилок робити їх
вчитись на них це банальні речі Можливо
але освітяни дуже бояться помилок трохи
ще більше ніж хтось інший Тому що наша
система освіти заточена на те щоб
сварити людей за помилки дай Бог там
відступити не дві клітинки а одну там за
поля зайти там не знаю якось не той
ручкою написати Ну як батько багатьох
дітей Я бачу це все теж кожен день і це
все ще лишається в системі от від цього
треба відійти треба виходити за поля
відступати трошки більше клітиночок і
використовувати різнокольорові ручки
в образному сенсі очевидно
і ще наступне Мені здається в системі
треба ставати більш людяною
це є повертаючись до попереднього свого
коментаря що треба звертатись до різних
груп людей
шукати нових клієнтів грубо кажучи тому
що
ми знаємо що контингент в системі
закладів професійно-технічної освіти був
колись там 400 з гаком тисяч колись був
і 500 гаком здається зараз скільки там
220 чи 230000 Тобто ми бачимо
довготерміновий тренд до зменшення цієї
кількості очевидно що напевно що не
зменшилась кількість людей які хочуть
отримати навички але вони перетекли в
інші інші системи чи навчання на
виробництві чи просто приватні чи просто
вчаться самі
ось тому у системі треба ставити людині
що і в тому сенсі що відповідати на
потреби різних абсолютно людей тих хто з
якими раніше не працювали дорослих людей
Ну і так далі І так далі ми будемо мати
На жаль велику кількість людей з
ментальними травами стресом з фізичними
травами і кількість цих людей на жаль
поки що збільшується і з ними теж треба
вміти працювати
знаходити до них підхід і це теж буде
важко тому людяність в Широкому сенсі в
сенсі навчальному тут буде дуже-дуже
важливою ну знову ж таки дуже Може
трошки філософські речі але вони
виливаються потім в практичні рішення
тому що якщо ви розумієте за якими
принципами Ви працюєте то потім простіше
транслювати це в якісь конкретній
навчальні програми і так далі Дякую так
Дякую шановний експертам якщо є питання
у вас є можливість їх задати я знаєте
хотів би зарезимувати що те про що ми
дискутуємо воно дуже лягає в контекст
програма її фоскелс яка була реалізована
і Сьогодні на жаль ми підходимо до її
такого завершення
Ну ми намагалися розвивати часткові або
короткотермінові формати навчання за
рахунок навчання на робочих місцях за
рахунок дуальної системи освіти
за рахунок
залучення закладів освіти
до здобуття
гнучких форматів
кваліфікацій
формальних кваліфікацій
з іншого боку ми також намагалися
сконцентруватися на підтримці викладачів
закладів освіти працювати в цьому новому
оточенні з новим ринком праці з новим
контингентом з різними цільовими групами
намагалися змінити позиціонування
освітніх послуг тому що зазвичай ну В
нас є якби система первинної професійної
підготовки і вона визначалася як
основному молодь яка туди заходить з
іншого боку затребуваність спеціальності
і кваліфікації зараз суттє змінюється і
треба надати можливість закладам освіти
виходити на ринок як зі збалансованим
портфелем освітніх послуг не
монопродуктовою компанією А
збалансованою
у нас разом з вами буде багато що
викликів буде виклик який ми сьогодні
чуємо щодо повернення людей які виїхали
які умови всередині країни в тому числі
в першу чергу з ринку праці мають бути
створені для того щоб люди які здобули
кваліфікації досить часто
пристойні кваліфікації за кордоном за
цей рік півтора
перебування були мотивовані повернутися
в Україну і принести цей інтелектуальний
ресурс для нашої держави що і як має це
відбуватися як має система освіти
реагувати на таких фахівців як мають
реагувати кваліфікаційні центри і служба
зайнятості якщо до них звертаються люди
зрозумілими
кваліфікаціями як треба синхронізуватись
з директивою ЄС щодо визнання
професійних кваліфікацій тому що як
визнаються академічні У нас є служба
визнання академічних кваліфікація А що
робити з професійними як Ну прирівняти
нашу зварника який би був
зварником чи навчався за кордоном і
приїхав і отримав би доступ до професій
тобто є ще регульовані професії
багато-багато питань попереду Але я
впевнений що
важкі часи дійсно створили дуже гарне
суспільство дуже гарне камюніті
професійне і роботодавці зараз які
продовжують працювати Вони також
демонструють дива стійкості мені навіть
Важко уявити як релакувати бізнес з
одних регіонів в інший це не тільки ну
фізична революція А це зміна великої
кількості долей людей тому я думаю що ми
як от
експерти на наші відкритій панелі
дискусійні першій половині дня казали що
закінчення - Це тільки початок Ми також
стоїмо на порозі великих змін на порозі
великих зрушень і Я запрошую всіх вас
долучатися до цього тому що це не
завдання окремого органу влади це не
завдання окремого роботодавця і от як
пан Валерій казав
домовленості угоди вони потрібні не
тільки письмові трьохсторонні вони може
потрібні чотирьохсторонній і 5 або і
двостороння але незалежно від цього вони
мають працювати тоді все буде
якість освіти і транзитивність до ринку
праці Дякую Дуже ми вклалися в наш час і
якщо мені ще дозволити я буду
сподіватися що
ви створили цей золотий фонд України
який закладає основи потенціал для
відбудови будь ласка підтримуємо зв'язки
і розвиваємо систему професійної освіти
в напрямку ринку праці разом
дякую
[оплески]
що я думаю що можемо розпочинати Так
пані Тетяна
думаю що будемо розпочинати час в дуже
швидко плине
Отже Доброго дня я вітаю всіх хто
приєднався до нашої сесії
Я Наталя Самойленко і ми розпочинаємо
панельну дискусію забезпечення якості
підготовки у системі професійної освіти
протягом наступної години ми будемо
говорити про зміст який формує якість
освіти А це насамперед професійні
освітні стандарти
освітні програми А також про інструменти
досягнення якості результатів навчання
і з нами
шановані спікери З якими ми будемо якраз
і обговорювати ці питання Отже Дозвольте
мені представити їх
Світлану Кравець
керівницю центру сучасних професій
технології навчання інституту
професійної освіти Національної академії
педагогічних наук України Наталя
Проценко
старший проект на менеджерка команди
підтримки реформ Міністерства освіти і
науки
Наталія Оверко
директорка
міжрегіонального центру
професійно-технічної освіти
художнього моделювання і дизайну міста
Львова Ірина смирнову методистку
навчально-методичного центру
професійно-технічної освіти у Сумській
області
Тетяну Верстюк заступницю директора
Чернівецького вищого комерційного
училища державного будівельної
економічного університету і Валентину
никифоренко заступницю директора
Київського вищого професійного училища
номер 33
але перш ніж розпочати наше обговорення
Дозвольте Хочу вам нагадати що
наприкінці нашої зустрічі Ви матимете
змогу задати запитання нашим спікерам як
в залі так і
учасники які доєднуються до нас онлайн в
залі ви можете передати свої запитання
нашим помічникам зокрема Тетяна і
в онлайн Ви можете написати свої
запитання в чаті і ми обов'язково
знайдемо можливість відповісти на всі
запитання які будуть бентежити вас в
контексті
нашої теми
Отже
починаємо ураховуючи всі виклики
сьогодення професійна освіта розуміє що
розвиток економіки не можливий без
належної підготовки кваліфікованого
робітника ну і звісно що
економіка потребує належної якості
робітничих кадрів
і забезпечення якості це одна із таких
питань які на сьогоднішній день
обговорюється І багато хто задає собі
запитання Що ж таке якість от Сьогодні
ми в цьому контексті трошечки
розберемося разом з нашими спікерами але
хочу зразу зауважити що у нас буде така
більш практично спрямованість
і ми сьогодні зможемо якраз практично
впевнитись які ж інструменти І що саме
на наш погляд і погляд наших спікерів
визначає якість професійної освіти і за
допомогою яких інструментів можна її
досягти
І звісно що і ця проблема І ця тематика
також була в полі зору протягом всього
Ріо до реалізацію проекту її фоскілс
Отже
якість чи забезпечення якість якості ну
в першу чергу це залежить мабуть від
основних трьох компонентів
зміст навчання
компетентність педагога
педагогічні технології звісно
матеріально-технічне забезпечення
тож зміст був і є
в полі зору завжди в полі зору
реформування професійної освіти
Якщо говорити про зміст то ми в першу
чергу розуміємо що це стандарти що це
освітні програми це професійні стандарти
це освітні стандарти і за інформацією
Міністерства освіти і науки на
сьогоднішній день У нас розроблено 151
держа відповідні стандарти і
національна агенція кваліфікації
говорить про те що вже 277 професійних
стандартів є в Україні
Отже
моє перше запитання буде до пані
Світлани Кравець
пані Світлана ми
я принаймні знаю да Що у вас великий
досвід в розроблені саме професійних і
освітніх стандартів
Тож як на вашу думку чи є освітні
стандарти на основі компетентності
компетентностей базовим інструментом
забезпечення якості освіти і в чому
полягає їх необхідність
особливість а можливо навпаки
проблемність будь ласка
дякую пані Наталя за запитання вітаю ще
раз учасників вже нашої вищої секції І
хочу сказати що питання якості освіти
сьогодні звучало від початку форуму так
і вже маємо четверту секцію де знову це
питання обговорюється звичайно Чому
якість освіти є така актуальним для
обговорення тому що це якість освіти -
це характеристика суспільства в цілому
характеристика розвитку суспільства і
зважаючи на ті виклики які сьогодні має
наша держава наше суспільство
має відреагувати не тільки в тих
нестандартних умовах якими зараз
перебуваємо якісною підготовкою
трудового потенціалу для відбудови А
взагалі в цілому якість освіти - це є
показник розвитку суспільства в
будь-яких умовах і власне якість це є
поліпшення системне поліпшення Ми не
можемо сказати що якість має бути
стандартизована якість чи
стандартизовані вимоги до тієї чи іншої
підготовки це динамічний процес який
постійно вимагає поліпшення а вже умови
політичні економічні соціальні культурні
впливають на розвиток цієї якості Разом
з тим ми маємо поліпшення якості освіти
в тому що ми уже впевнено йдемо на
засадах компетентнісного підходу Як ви
розроблені професійних стандартів так і
в розроблені освітніх стандартів і
освітніх програм в принципі
компетентність не підхід визнаний в
європейських країнах як базові підхід
який інтегрує ті підходи які
забезпечують якість освіти
особистісно-орієнтований технологічний
цифровізацію культурологічний і низку
інших підходів і ми вже маємо в цьому
добрі успіхи що ми на цій основі вже
певним чином впевне стоїмо на
компетентнісні основі більш того ми
розвиваємо компетентність на підхід і
підходи до дискрипторів до Скажімо так
декомпозиції компетентності на
дискриптори знання уміння навички
комунікація автономність і
відповідальність відповідно до
європейської рамки кваліфікації і це теж
уже добре такий добра основа для
розвитку якості і проектування змісту
освіти друге що я хочу сказати що якщо
говорити про інструменти забезпечення
якості це якщо підходи принципи
зарубіжний досвід це більш питання науки
педагогіки ми ще маємо такий інструменти
як як же сказала економічні політичні
управлінські І власне одними з таких
інструментів які об'єднує оце
економічний і управлінський аспект це
можна сказати є професі освітні
стандарти оскільки професійні стандарти
нам дають вимоги для проектування змісту
для потреб економіки освітні стандарти
більш стосуються управління в системі
освіти і підготовки кваліфікованих
робітників на вимогу цієї економіки так
от власне цієї освітньої професійні
стандарти мають свою еволюцію і Ми всі
прекрасно можемо бачити як
еволюціонували професійні стандарти від
перших паспортів професії до
сьогоднішніх нових методичних
рекомендацій які вже працюють на нові
стандарти і якими вже знаємо ці
професійні стандарти є також саме
еволюцію проходить і освітні стандарти
вони розроблялися за однією методикою за
іншою за наступною тепер ми поступово
переходимо до вже стандартів освітніх
які мають відповідати тільки
професійному стандарту якщо він такий є
Отже я вже так дуже багато про переваги
є переваги є переваги
нас є проблеми є те що процес має бути
більш такий інтегрованіший має бути
процес синергії І такої якщо то якщо є
професійний то негайно треба освітні
якщо є освітній то треба освітня
програма і наступне якщо ми орієнтуємося
на особистість То якщо є потреба
особистості то негайно цей зміст
професійних і освітніх має бути
оновлений і
Скажімо так гнучкий для потреби
особистості і для потреби економіки
більш такі рекомендації щодо конкретних
змін Я можливо скажу У підсумку а поки
що така моя думка що процеси є процеси
мають переваги і мають деякі ще шляхи
для розвитку А це і буде якість
добре Дякую
Ну і навіть пан коржевський на
попередній сесії сказав що
професійний
професійний стандарт освітня програма і
оцінювання тобто
далі стандарт ми розуміємо що
професійний стандарт Ну поки що наразі
ми працюємо в системі освітнього
стандарту І дійсно як зазначили еволюція
є але ж рухаючись рухаючись вперед в і
рухаючись саме за європейськими
стандартами Ми також розуміємо над тим
що треба
Ну працювати саме над програмами
освітніми і саме програма освітня
якісна бо Від цього залежить який зміст
методу закладемо да залежить і в певній
мірі результат навчання і в рамках
даного проекту
ми доволі довго працювали над
розробленням освітніх програм і про це
вже сьогодні було зазначено на головній
панелі і я хочу передати словом пані
Наталі Проценко щодо саморозроблення
освітніх програм
щодо їх впровадження вже у нас в системі
професійної професійно-технічної освіти
це перше і
по-друге чи ці освітні програми вони
можуть сприяти якраз от тому тренду які
є У нас сьогодні в Україні
навчання впродовж життя
будь ласка
Шановні колеги я дійсно дуже рада те що
я змогла долучитися до спільнот
повернутися в спільноту долучитися і
якраз спробувати на те завдання яке було
поставлено що потрібно розробляти
освітні програми як є нові стандарти Ми
пам'ятаємо цю історію що ще не було
освітніх стандартів нових близькі
професійні і треба було робити освітні
програми ви знаєте
працюючи з задоволеннями отримали Я
думаю що всі ми працювали в п'яти
регіонах було напрацьовано на 20
кваліфікацій Отакі програми
хороші нехороші потребують допрацювання
Можливо десь недолугі ці програми але
пішов процес безпосередньо побудови
самої програми ви знаєте коли от я
займалася цим питанням і аналізувала
дуже багато літератури і нормативних
документів європейських я все собі
задавала запитання Ну що ми знову
граємось
діти гралися до цього грали знову
граємося знову щось ми придумаємо щось
нове пояснити на пальцях комусь в чому ж
різниця між тими навчальними щоб в нас
були робочі навчальні програми да І
тепер називається освітній програмі і ви
знаєте тепер коли от я слухаю я собі
думаю Ну не нам трошки не вистачає само
розуміння освітня програма - це коли
присвоюється освітній рівень освітня
кваліфікація все інше то я навчальні
програми тобто можуть бути присвоїтись
професійній кваліфікації А на освітню
ось наприклад в нас є повна загальна
середня кваліфікація так кваліфікований
робітник в системі в нашій фаховий
молодший бакалавр В наступні в
наступному рівні освіти і так далі
так ось
чим відрізняються програми зараз а тим
що вони орієнтовані на результат ви
знаєте коли ми раніше працювали з
програмами ми були орієнтувались на
процес Тобто нам потрібно запустити
загальну професійна підготовка були у
нас типові програми ми це все вичитували
да десь можливо викладачі електротехніки
там чи матеріалознавство він міг з
викладачем спецдиплін погоджуватись десь
орієнтуватися Але це був сам процес
зараз все орієнтується на результат дві
таких складових це
час і кошти все це нас змушує робити
щось оптимізувати тому оці освітні
програми які Почали будуватися вони були
вони орієнтуються на Результат навчання
який вже закладається в ось цих освітніх
стандартах але так трапилося що ми
працювали без освітнього стандарту і
спробували зробити освітню програму
первинної професійної підготовки на
основі професійного стандарту в принципі
я ніколи не хочу образити бо це
величезний труд педагогів робити освітні
стандарти величезний рік робиться
професійний рік освітній
ліцензування якщо це нова професія
ліцензування або і атестація інший треба
затвердити ці програми тобто треба в
часі В принципі це все можна робити якщо
ми робимо ось цей модульний підхід це не
нове тому що ми вже давно ми вже з вами
по 100 років цієї системи профтехосвіти
перебуваємо і ми розуміємо що модульний
підхід він був Моп започатковував лише
на початку в 2000-х в принципі десь теж
хтось спробував це працювати але
сам модуль орієнтується вже на щось
завершене це не просто фрагмент програми
це не просто кусочок там в часі Да там
перший семестр там другий семестр або
фрагмент там кусочок першого семестру це
блок блок цієї програми який о рослини
на якісь кінцевий результат з яким можна
вийти на ринок праці і От коли ми це
зможемо побудувати зможемо виокремити у
нас тоді з'являється ресурс побудови
якраз формування мікрокваліфікації я
Юрій міхалича я бачу дуже рада що він
тут присутній Це дуже гарно лягає дуже
гарне лягає в нашій програмі коли може
з'явитися мікрокваліфікація коли може
з'явитися частково кваліфікація і
звичайно що повна кваліфікація
професійна кваліфікація але
В чому є виклики от в чому я зіткнулась
у викликах
ми говоримо про те що гнучкі повинні
бути освітні програми Наприклад взяти
регіон Північний от Сумський і взяти
наприклад Миколаїв це Південний Да там
підготовка кухаря може бути з абсолютно
різна Результати будуть однакові але
побудова програми різна Чому Тому що це
є по-перше
природні зони Да там дуже холодно там
дуже тепло Це різні продукти там десь
дуже багато риби а там десь дуже багато
м'яса і тому будуючи Ось такі програми
це все в принципі можна врахувати і це
потрібно це робити але це час треба
навчити людей робити Ось такі програми А
коли вони захочуть робити програми не
захоче робити програми коли я побачивши
їм потрібен клієнт коли кожен заклад
буде хотіти що йому потрібно буде
орієнтуватися на те що у нього буде
класна програма про нього будуть знати
до нього будуть іти і він буде дійсно
готувати робити цю розробляти програму
другий момент в тому що
зафіксувати оці результати Мені
подобається як в Європі говорять у нас
наприклад говорять Вибух з навчального
закладу а в них дуже гарно кажуть у них
ранній вихід із навчальної програми або
з освітньої програми ранній вихід і коли
учень здобувач виходе ну хотілося б що
ще зафіксувати його ці результати
навчання щоб він вийшов на ринок праці
щоб Кошти які витрачені бюджетом були
недармові Тому можливо внести невеличку
невеличку таку пропозицію до постанови
стосовно документів державного зразка
наприклад свідоцтво про присвоєння
підвищення робітничої кваліфікації і
добавити кваліфікація в дужках повна
часткова кваліфікація Тобто це можна
зробити тому
те щоб по програмам скажу те що завершую
допрацьовувати конструктор освітньої
програми векселі до кожного аркуша щоб
була інструкція щоб кожен міг зайти
працювати і сам зробити таку програму
Тому я думаю що ми продовжимо серію
вебінарів таких як ми робили Ну а по
коротким програмам тому що це наслідок
оцих освітніх програм Я думаю що
передасте слово да Ані Наталія тобто
пані Наталя ви в принципі можете
стверджувати чи стверджувати про те що
саме такі програми вони можуть
забезпечити гнучкість так освітньої і
професійної
траєкторії
або під конкретна робоче місце якщо це
треба в регіоні або під конкретні
технології або під конкретні наприклад
засоби виробництва Да там наприклад
якесь обладнання під якихось тобто
можливо побудувати в принципі такі
програми можливо будувати Ну можливо
конструктор допоможеться
добре Дякую Ну от якраз впродовж е-е
цієї нашої розмови дав і в цьому
контексті а от саме практичний кейс він
підтверджує це міжрегіонального центру
Наталія оверкова вам будь ласка
місто Львів Да бо саме Львів можна
сказати що є флагманом в започаткуванні
да розроблення і впровадження Таких
короткострокових програм які дозволяють
швидко виходити
робітнику на ринок праці можна будь
ласка до пані спікерки Ви знаєте Вони
перші
найбільше підготували якраз слухачів за
короткостроковими таким навчанням тому в
мене даремно її вибрали успіх
Розкажи що було Добре що погано Доброго
дня колеги дякую за запрошення і
можливість власне поділитися досвідом А
ви знаєте так минулий рік був для нас
таким визначальним оскільки в нашому
закладі ми маємо багато і про підготовки
власне курсів перепідготовки І власне
освіти дорослого населення
перекваліфікації але
в березні місяці минулого року
така виникла ідея і ми її успішно
зреалізували разом з
навчально-практичним центром за
підтримки ООН це були власне ідея
короткотермінового навчання для
внутрішньо переміщених осіб І
такої місії цих курсів цих цього
навчання власне було
соціалізація власне ну найперших жінок
перепрошую за таку гендерність Так але
тому що в нас було багато жінок які
приїхали до нас Вони проживали в
гуртожитку навчального закладу і такою
метою було
залучити їх на таке короткотерміноване
навчання тому з якими викликами ми
стикнулися це насправді була емоційна
оця адаптація таких жінок тому що коли
ми їм запропонували вони не зразу
зрозуміли для чого це і насправді перші
діячі які в нас були це було 8 таких
бажаючих А пізніше насправді ми за майже
від березня до серпня Ми навчили 78
жінок це вони прийшли короткотермінові
курси які були
адаптовані
створена була навчальна програма І
власне
76-72 години за три тижні з здобуттям
часткових кваліфікацій ми провели таке
навчання
Добре дякую я
такий от навчання так воно звісно
супроводжується для того щоб воно було
якісним так воно звісно супроводжувалось
певними навчальними матеріалами
оцінювальними матеріалами так для щоб
можна було
саме оцінити і потім випустити саме
цього фахівця на ринок праці Я так
розумію що саме ваш досвід дозволив і
працевлаштуватися всім цим жінкам і в
подальшому продовжити свою кар'єру
нашими стали власною роботодавці вони
допомагали і були активним включалися в
розробку навчальної програми в власне з
їхньою ініціативи були злочині ті
компетенції які мали би оволодіти за
короткий час так щоб швидко адаптуватися
до виробничих потреб саме підприємств
Дякую І
звісно Оце і є мабуть ну одним із
критеріїв також і якості
надання наших послуг і
ця якось якість також і залежить від
створення певних умов в безпосередньо
якщо говорити зараз в закладах
професійної професійно-технічної освіти
Ну і сьогодні
також враховуючи ті виклики і пандемію і
війну то
в основному процес навчання поєднує
сьогодні як дистанційні технології так і
офлайн-технології тобто змішане навчання
і мабуть все ж таки
саме оці
деталізація Да вона настільки вже
глибоко увійшла в наш процес що
надалі ми вже нікуди не дінемося нам
тільки треба рухатись вперед і
цьому треба навчати Бо саме якість
залежить від певного професійного рівня
наших педагогічних працівників і
цьому також впродовж реалізації проекту
було приділено дуже багато часу і
як же впроваджувались саме Digital
технології яким чином навчали
педагогічних працівників як далі
працювали і Працюємо з цими технологіями
хочу
запитати у смірнової Ірини У пані Ірини
в будь ласка Ірина Що ви можете сказати
Вітаю колеги трошки Хочу поділитися
досвідом з нашої Сумської області
взагалі
Якщо говорити про забезпечення якості
підготовки у системі професійної освіти
шляхом впровадження цифрових технологій
шляхом формування у педагогів готовності
до їх використання
то ми це зрозуміли ще у 2016 році коли в
нашій області Ми створили школу розвитку
іт-компетентності
ось саме тоді ми власне почали роботу з
формування у педагогів готовності до
впровадження цифрових технологій І хочу
сказати що на початку свого існування
діяльність школи була орієнтована на
педагогічних працівників
професійно-технічної освіти але так
сталося що вона стала популярною і серед
педагогічних працівників закладів
загальноосвітньої підготовки фахової
перевищує навіть вищої освіти і не
тільки нашої області а й багатьох інших
областей України
коли ми створили школу дійсно ми
починали з того що
забезпечували навчання педагогів
використання цифрових ресурсів під час
очного навчання тобто про впровадження
дистанційних технологій в закладах
освіти Ми ще навіть на той момент
не думали Скажімо так ми навчали
створювати електронні тести сучасні
презентації
забезпечували використання інтерактивних
дошок в закладах освіти і
власне
створювали електронні навчальні
матеріали які полегшували оцінювання
навичок знань здобувачів освіти
зацікавлювали учнів і легко
впроваджувались в учний
навчальний процес Але у 2020 році
ситуація змінилася пандемія потім у 2022
році відбулося військове вторгнення
Росії в Україну і
в нашій області були активні бойові дії
наразі в деяких регіонах тривають тому я
якби без перебільшення можу сказати що
заклади освіти просто були змушені
впроваджувати
впроваджувати дистанційні технології
навчання і в цей час Школа розвитку it
компетентності набула уже такої більш
широкої популярності серед педагогічних
працівників
Ми уже на той момент почали активно
розвивати створене нами цифрове освітнє
середовище це сайт школи розвитку
іт-компетентності відеоканал в YouTube і
навчальне середовище Спочатку ми
використовували Google класи Зараз ми
уже використовуємо Moodle
також Наша Школа розвитку it
компетентності має свій особливий
фірмовий стиль який ми використовуємо і
[музика]
такий рекламні Скажімо так
рекламних матеріалах у
так логотип школи it компетентності ми
постійно просуваємо
можливість навчання у школі у
різних соціальних мережах на нашому
сайті І власне все це призводить до того
що дощ школи it приходять педагогічні
працівники з різних областей
Вибачте будь ласка А скажіть будь ласка
взагалі проблеми на сьогоднішній день
вони є
запровадженні от таких от
digital-технологій в освітній процес Чи
стикаєтесь ви з такими проблемами
насправді ми стикаємо якби ми
стикаємося з проблемами впровадження з у
закладах освіти Тобто ми їм допомагаємо
ми їх консультуємо
до нас звертаються з такими проблемами
так наприклад в одному ж закладі освіти
в нашій області були проблеми із
впровадженням дистанційного навчання
вони до нас звернулися ми допомогли їм
розгорнути систему Google в Express
froducation в їх закладі освіти показали
як здійснювати контроль створили систему
електронних класів і зрештою провели
навчання педагогічних працівників
по використанню цих класів Також у нас
Звісно якщо говорити про роботу школи то
проблема є в тому щоб шукати натхнення
шукати нові ресурси як їх
використовувати
і скажу що у цьому нам
реально допомагає участь у міжнародних
програмах у міжнародних
проєктах От наприклад її фоскіз було
учасниками багатьох навчальних курсів І
власне
[музика]
зрозуміли як впроваджувати дистанційні
технології системно Якщо говорити про
досвід області То коли це все починалося
у 2020 році то у нас Кожен педагог
використовував ті засоби які в яких він
міг працювати на сьогоднішній день
завдяки реалізації програми її фоскіз ми
маємо доступ до
спеціальних середовищ таких як Google в
explace як офіс 365 Moodle наші заклади
освіти їх розгорнули включаючи
навчально-методичний центр і активно їх
використовують і Я звісно хочу
підкреслити що це
значно впливає на якість підготовки у
системи професійної освіти пані Наталія
є якесь Ще запитання чи додатково про те
що
Ірина була
гіперактивна на одному навчанні яку
проводив
представник із Фіджі і ось коли він
побачив на яких платформах працюють тому
що він ділився досвідом як Фіджі
впроваджують дистанційне навчання які
платформи Які ресурси використовують і
ось коли він побачив що витворяють наші
працівники з якими на яких вони
платформах і з якими ресурсами працюють
він був Просто здивований він потім
говорив Ну да Ну да так от але я хотіла
б задати питання пані Ірино Ви знайомі з
багатьма платформами на яких можна
працювати з отими цифровими ресурсами
правильно я говорю Так скажіть будь
ласка які на вашу думку яка платформа от
найбільш доступна для наших закладів як
і як швидко навчитись працювати на цій
платформі це ще не створювати ресурси
просто працювати на цій платформі яка
най сама найдоступніша і простіша і як
скільки часу для її для навчання щоб
працювати в цій платформою Якщо говорити
про системи для дистанційного навчання
то я все ж таки ну моя особиста думка це
Google як Spaces тому що більшість із
педагогічних працівників вже працюють з
приватними аккаунтами gmail і якщо
відбуватиметься перехід то він буде вже
не такий болісний Скажімо так
скільки часу Ну я думаю що тут більше
часу
займе сам процес розгортання цієї
системи в закладі освіти організація
якщо ми це робили це близько місяця Ну
можливо плюс-мінус
Два тижні це як мінімум
Добре дякую
Це також Є якість освіти Ну і Одним із
показників якості також чи результату да
показників якості є також і ефективне
оцінювання і
саме от компонент один із компонентів
програми її фоскіз і цьому дуже
приділяли велику увагу було проведено
ряд навчань в яких взяли участь наші
педагогічні працівники і мабуть процес
оцінювання він є
важким і таким складним не лише для
здобувача освіти да А І звісно в першу
чергу для педагогічного працівника то
будь ласка
моє запитання до пані Тетяни прошу
поділитися
своїм досвідом участі саме в таких
проектах і
що Це дало І як це впливає саме оці от
інструменти оцінювання да впливають на
ефективність і якість
Доброго дня Хочу сказати що завдяки
програмі euroskills мала можливість у
грудні місяці Пройти навчання і з
розроблення завдань для оцінювання на
основі компетентностей
учасниками даного тренінгу було біля 40
колег із закладів професійно-технічної
освіти де ми мали можливість дізнатися
про навчання та оцінювання на основі
компетентностей дізнатися про
методологію розробки інструментів
оцінювання а також мали можливість
практично застосувати дані знання курс
був складний оскільки це був грудень
місяць це було відключення
електроенергії і крім цього треба було
виконувати завдання треба було складати
оте оцінювання Використовуючи різні
інструменти
хочу сказати що було проведено дуже
багато занять
розглядалися наші
оцінювання наші інструменти давався
детальний аналіз кожного інструменту І
хоча це робили фактично досвідчені
педагоги майже до кожного педагога були
зауваження тому кожен педагог по
декілька разів змінював оцей інструмент
навчання
інструмент оцінювання ми знаємо що
оцінювання проходить на кожному із
етапів і є декілька типів оцінювання і
якщо ми зараз сьогодні розмовляли і про
кваліфікаційні центри і попі про
підвищення кваліфікації і про
перепідготовку знову ж таки треба
розробити певну систему оцінювання для
того щоб визначити рівень знань тієї чи
іншої особи яка хоче здобути іншу
кваліфікацію і знову ж треба розробляти
різні інструменти оцінювання На даному
тренінгу розробляли теоретичні тести а
також розробляли
оцінювання для практичних завдань якщо
теоретичні тести - це ще можна було
більш-менш це було не важко зробити хоча
для розробки тестів для теоретичного
навчання
використовувалася спрощена
економія Блума яка складалася із трьох
рівнів це рівень C1 C2 і C3 то для
оцінювання практичних навичок
застосовувалася
таксономія Сімпсона яка також складалася
із трьох рівнів Це був рівень R1 р1п-2 і
п3 Тетяна Я вибачаюсь що перебуває було
у нас все ж таки регламентом але все ж
таки яким чином впливають ці інструменти
на якість
Ну я думаю що у даних інструментах
оцінювання мають для створення мають
бути залучені самі роботодавці тому що
якщо брати практичне оцінювання ми маємо
акцентувати увагу на те що на здобувач
повинен отримати щоб він вільно міг
працювати Тому на якість оцінювання якщо
ми зможемо залучити до розробки даних
е-е даних інструментів оцінювання
роботодавців це значно вплине на їхню
виробничу спроможність і на можливість
їх гарно ефективно працювати після
здобуття тієї чи іншої професії Добре
дякую Таким чином ми знову ж таки плавно
підходимо до
центрів кваліфікації оцінювання і
говоримо саме про те що сьогодні ну
наших громадян все більше змушує
переходити на інформаційної не навчання
і в саме в цьому нам допомагають ті
центри
кваліфікації які на сьогоднішній день
створюються і доволі стрімкими темпами і
пан Баланюк сьогодні зазначав щоб вже
209 таких центрів працює і третина з
яких саме відкрили свої двері на базі
закладів професійної
професійно-технічної освіти і сьогодні з
нами один із перших закладів
професійно-професійного технічної освіти
де на сьогодні
ефективно працює такий центр
це Київське училище номер 33 Тож будь
ласка Я прошу пані
Валентину в поділитися досвідом
саме Ну вже
не створення даного центра а саме
ефективної роботи підтвердження
кваліфікацій присвоєння кваліфікації
так Доброго дня шановні колеги ну перш
за все хочу сказати що наш навчальний
заклад вже більше 30 років підготовлює
кваліфікованих робітників за професією
кухар та кондитер ще з 2018 року наш
заклад є суб’єктом підтвердження
результатів неформального навчання з
професії кухар Можливо тому нам було не
досить важко відкрити кваліфікаційний
центр так і пройти акредитацію в
національному агентстві кваліфікації за
двома професіями кухар та кондитер
наш заклад ви з липня 22-го року
пройшов акредитацію та внесений в реєстр
кваліфікаційних центрів
Ну насправді
яка мета діяльності нашого центру це
присвоєння підтвердження кваліфікації та
визнання результатів неформальної та
інформальної освіти Тобто всі особи які
працюють на підприємстві набули там
знання та навички можуть звернутися до
нашого центру та підтвердити свою
кваліфікацію і отримати свідоцтво
державного зразка саме з цим документом
вони зможуть подальшому Більше
розвиватися
крокувати верх по своїм професійним
сходинкам
і також підвищується дуже самооцінка в
таких людей і звичайно що простіше
влаштуватися на роботу Так як у них є
документ який визнається державою
на даний момент ну з 2018 року і по
даний час
в нашому закладі отримали свідоцтво про
присвоєння кваліфікації
за різними кваліфікаційними рівнями 356
осіб буквально на минулому тижні у нас
було дві особи які
без проблем підтвердили свої
кваліфікацію отримали свідоцтво
ну основна цільова аудиторія
наших кваліфікаційних центрів Я думаю як
і всіх так і в нас це особи 30+, тобто
ті люди які можна сказати до цього віку
навчалися але зараз вони не мають часу
не мають змогу щоб закінчити навчальний
заклад і отримати
підтверджуючі документ саме для цього ми
і покликані нашу підтвердити їм цю
кваліфікацію і видати відповідний
документ адже наразі бізнес знаємо що
він не може чекати Бо багато працівників
під час таких кваліфікованих працівників
під час повномасштабного вторгнення
виїхали за кордон і наш бізнес зараз
потребує саме робітників в яких
кваліфікації підтверджена тобто я думаю
що це наразі є обов'язковим
Добре дякую і
час на жаль так швидко сплинув і але так
як ми обіцяли що
у нас повинні буде ще запитання Я так
розумію і є декілька запитань зали
тож я хочу
адресувати одне одне із запитань і
мабуть
можливо воно буде і для всіх адресоване
Да хто бажає може дати відповідь
бо взагалі-то забезпечені якості освіти
воно також залежить і від тієї синергії
да між
співпраці з роботодавцями закладу освіти
і роботодавця тож розробка професійних
стандартів поки що і розробка освітніх
стандартів і освітніх програм це та
спільна спільна робота це той от саме
зміст який буде закладений він і буде
визначати може визначити саме ту якість
і в
підготовленого робітника безпосередньо
Який необхідний саме для нашого
працездавця тож таке запитання
Що може стати мотиватором для бізнесу
громадськості
освітян для розроблення і модернізації
змісту освіти
будь ласка
Я ще раз будь ласка візьму запитання Що
може стати мотиватором для бізнесу
громадськості освітя для розроблення
стандартів і оновлення змісту освіти
Шановні колеги це питання таке водночас
є просте і зрозуміли вже напевно в
контексті сьогоднішнього заходу але має
ще таких глобальне підґрунтя
на попередній секції говорилось про
м'які навички і основна з них
відповідальність учнів ми говорили про
місто відповідальність учнів здобувачів
освіти про відповідальність їхню
щодо виконання трудових функцій Я хочу
сказати що мотивація до якоїсь
діяльності це є внутрішня спонука і
кожен громадянин України який бачить Я
вважаю мотиватори в нас зараз більш ніж
очевидні вони просто кризові вже в
деякій мірі кожен відповідальний
громадянин який при належний до тієї чи
іншої діяльності теж він має мати цю
відповідальність вирішувати ті чи інші
проблеми Якщо ми говоримо про розвиток
економіки у воєнний і повоєнний період і
якісну підготовку трудового потенціалу
то почнемо кожен з того що кожен має
мати внутрішню мотивацію до якоїсь
діяльності зокрема до розроблення
оновлення змісту професійних стандартів
і оновлення освітніх програм Якщо
говорити про мотивації мотиватори такі
зовнішні то я б акцентувала на таких
трьох основних завданнях ми щиро вдячні
тим мотиваторам які сприяють
донорські підтримці нашої України це
міжнародні проекти які мають чітку
програму чіткі завдання які
скажемо так окреслюються завдання у
певному проекті а як ми знаємо кожен
проект має мати конкретний результат і
тому я вважаю досить гарним результатом
це створення професійних освітніх
стандартів і освітніх програм в межах
цієї програми які вже мають початок
початок і закінчення ну скажемо так не
настільки закінчення скільки такий цикл
професійний освітній освітня програма
кваліфікаційний центр і підтвердження
кваліфікацій є такі прекрасні вже
приклади наприклад у Закарпатській
області можемо згодом про це поговорити
Тому що немає часу Отже виходимо з того
що міжнародні проекти закладають таку
добру основу для звуження проектів на
регіонах можна організовувати проектну
діяльність на регіонах з створення осіб
професійних стандартів для потреби
економіки чи для конкретного виробника
така проектна діяльність має певну групу
група зацікавлена група працює над
професійним стандартом і одночасно НАТО
освітнім стандартом це теж є добре
мотиватором звичайно фінансовою
мотиватор має свої вплив на
сучасну особистість яка розуміє що
робота має бути оплачувана це залежить
вже від керівництва того чи іншого
закладу освіти чи
роботодавця який має відповідні
механізми стимулювання цієї роботи і це
буде мати добрий результат і мотивуючи
людину до якоїсь діяльності ми чітко
розуміємо що ця людина ще буде готова до
наступної діяльності це якби
капіталовкладення хоча в нашій країні
воно може бути і невелике але воно в
нашій країні є успішне бо наші люди
готові працювати і без таких
мотиваторів і
саме мотивація я хотіла щоб сказати про
вихід з внутрішньої системи педагогічної
вихід з свого закладу в екстравертну
педагогічну систему це об'єднання це
популяризація як з освіти як
популяризація тих продуктів які вже є це
дуже своєчасне тестування освіти на
професійний стандарт я б навіть сказала
коли професійний стандарт на обговоренні
Можливо ще не на заявці бо на заявці він
ще може потім скасувати заявку А коли
він вже на обговоренні то вже має бути
робоча група де створення освітнього
стандарту чи освітньої програми і
залучати фахівців Із тієї групи яка
розробляла професійний стандарт
мотивація буде розвиватися в синергії і
мотивація має внутрішню відповідальність
кожної особистості за розвиток нашої
країни
я слухаю професорка вже да А ще напишіть
професорка і я собі думаю мотиватором
для наших педагогів Було б класно якби
Скажем так той Хто розробив стандарт Да
там професійний освітній і зразу їм
давали б наукове звання захист допуск
вільний допуск до десертації І я так
думаю що пані Світлана у нас з'явилося б
дуже багато
дійсно це дійсно була б мотивація тому
що щоб зробити стандарт треба
перелопатити стільки літератури і Це
буде продукт авторський це навіть не те
що скопійований десь да скажемо з
посиланнями на когось А це був би
авторський продукт і можна було б
нормативно-правове поле змінювати бути
треба змінювати треба змінювати Добре
дякую чи є у когось іще думки з приводу
цього можливо ще в залі є запитання до
наших спікерів
або якісь репліки
добре Дякуємо Ну не на жаль онлайн
також нас дивляться і ми дуже раді
щастя Так вибачте нещастя але на жаль я
хотіла сказати що немає запитань але то
нічого і сьогодні в такій ну короткий
можна сказати зустрічі але ми змогли
трошечки проаналізувати Да і
доволі швидко і досягнення в реалізації
саме в контексті забезпечення якості
освіти
і проекту її фоскілс і зупинилась на тих
ну зробили Такі от акценти да основні
акценти на тих складниках які саме
забезпечують якість професійної
підготовки Отже шановні друзі всім
Дякуємо за активну участь кро маємо
вперед крокуємо до перемоги
всього найкращого і
хочу нагадати і хочу нагадати що нас ще
чекають
фоє для заключного такого от етапу для
спілкування ще неформального Тож до
нових зустрічей дякуємо